وتعليقا على اعتقال رئيس الحزب الجمهوري
عصام الشابي قبل ايام قال رئيس جبهه
الخلاص الوطني احمد نجيب الشاب ان عصام
الشابي لم يتامر على البلاد وان السلطات
لن تجد ما تواجه به الراي العامه الوطنيه
الاتهامه واضافت تصريح للجزيره ان حمله
الاعتقالات تتوسع وتعم كل الاوساط ولم تعد
تقتصر على سياسيين مؤكدا على ان هناك حاله
من التخبط والعبث حسب تعبيره
هناك حاله من التخبل واحاذا من العبث هي
سببها
الخيبه التي عاشها السيد قيس سعيد اثناء
الانتخابات التشريعيه في دورتها الاولى
ودورتها الثانيه حيث سحب سحب
المواطن ثقته بالكامل من مساله السياسي ثم
فشله الثريه في اداره الشان الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي تونس على ابواب الانهيار
والافلاس وكذلك عزف مطبق في اداره
العلاقات الخارجيه لتونس كل هذه النتائج
تجعله يهرب الى الامام في محاوله لاسكات
الاصوات الحره